[Música]
hola en este vídeo hablaremos sobre el
contenido que ofrecemos a profesores y
estudiantes y explicaremos que lo hace
tan especial puedes ver todos los cursos
disponibles en khan academy haciendo
clic en el menú desplegable en la
esquina superior izquierda de nuestra
página web tenemos cursos completos con
contenido teórico y práctico organizados
por asignaturas desde primaria hasta
secundaria preparatoria e incluso en
algunos casos para los primeros ciclos
de la universidad nuestros cursos de
matemáticas están alineados al modelo
educativo de méxico y a la currícula
nacional de perú todos nuestros
contenidos están completamente en
español también tenemos diversos
contenidos en ciencias economía finanzas
computación y mentalidad de crecimiento
además siempre estamos trabajando para
agregar nuevo contenido
haz clic en cualquiera de tus clases de
khan academy y la pestaña tareas
mostrará una lista con la secuencia para
el curso seleccionado la mayoría de los
cursos se dividen en unidades y en cada
unidad hay varias lecciones las
lecciones incluyen recursos teóricos y
prácticos como vídeos artículos y
ejercicios para el perú al frente de
cada unidad lección y actividad el
código de las competencias de la
currícula nacional indica las
habilidades que se están trabajando en
ese componente y si movemos el cursor
sobre el código podemos verificar la
descripción de la competencia tal como
aparece en la currícula nacional en
muchos cursos las pruebas combinan la
práctica de varias lecciones previas las
unidades terminan con una prueba que
verifica el nivel de comprensión de toda
la unidad es decir cuanto aprendió tu
estudiante
[Música]
encontrar el contenido que buscas en
khan academy es muy fácil puedes buscar
cursos habilidades y temas utilizando el
buscador en la esquina superior
izquierda de la pantalla aquí debes
ingresar el nombre de lo que necesitas
por ejemplo fracciones y además es
posible filtrar los resultados por
vídeos artículos ejercicios o programas
[Música]
utilizamos gráficos e imágenes
interactivos para enseñarles a los
alumnos a leer e interpretar datos con
diferentes tipos de preguntas explora
nuestro contenido para conocer la
variedad de actividades prácticas que
ofrecemos nuestra plataforma ofrece una
réplica instantánea después de responder
una pregunta el estudiante sabe
inmediatamente si ha respondido
correctamente o no los estudiantes que
no avanzan en un problema en particular
pueden recibir ayuda como vídeos y
artículos relacionados consejos sobre
estrategias de resolución y
justificaciones que explican por qué una
respuesta específica es correcta o
incorrecta en resumen nuestro contenido
es fácil de usar y estimula la capacidad
de razonamiento de los estudiantes
dejando en claro que pueden aprender
cualquier cosa queremos que los
estudiantes sientan que están
aprendiendo de acuerdo a sus necesidades
individuales para obtener más
información sobre carne academy visita
nuestro centro de ayuda y consulta
nuestra sección de preguntas frecuentes
[Música]